and welcome to hannity and tonight we
begin with this fox news alert guess
what every american is suffering there
is no question joe biden's policies have
been an unmitigated disaster both at
home and abroad as a result joe biden is
now the most unpopular president in the
modern era now you'd be hard-pressed to
find anyone who approves of his
performance in office yesterday look at
this crowd a handful 30 people showed up
to the president's big publicized speech
in new hampshire can you imagine if
donald trump held an event and only 30
people showed up
what would the media reaction be then
of course many of biden's problems they
are very obvious but they are hurting
the american people his obvious
declining cognitive abilities his public
bouts of anger confusion shaking hands
with the air joe's constant stream of
lying and blame and the ongoing scandal
of course surrounding zero experienced
hunter and of course the biden family
syndicate but at the very core of
biden's failed presidency are his
terrible policies and all of these
policies are hurting you
we the american people biden like any
modern democrat is required to prove his
loyalty to the religious cult of climate
alarmism he cannot deviate in order to
demonstrate this devotion biden took a
wrecking ball to america's oil and gas
industry on day one and naturally
predictably gas prices went way up
heating and cooling prices went way up
the price of goods and services which
required transportation and energy they
also went up everything you buy at every
store you go to is costing a hell of a
lot more add to these rising costs biden
pump trillions of dollars into what is
an already hot economy much of it in the
name of climate change alarmism and
according to onefoxnews.com report some
of those funds earmarked for covert 19
relief oh their investigation shows they
were used by joe biden's epa to pay for
grants promoting quote green
infrastructure and environmental justice
and one nonprofit actually received
money for storytelling and tree walks to
increase awareness surrounding
inequitable tree canopy cover
what the hell is this
now this is the same administration that
ran out of cova tests monoclonal
antibodies over christmas and that's how
they're spending covert relief money now
americans from every race every
background they're struggling under joe
biden's crippling record high inflation
most of them do not have time to explore
racist tree canopies now those with
fixed incomes the poor the middle class
they are getting hurt the the worst with
many americans now forced to dip into
their retirement savings to battle this
40-year high of inflation but the
eco-socialists that now run the
democratic new green deal socialist
party they're they're happy they don't
seem to care about retirees they don't
care about so many americans living
paycheck to paycheck they never have and
nor do they seem to care at all about
the high price of gasoline
we're told if you don't like it get used
to it until we have clean new energy and
buy yourself an electric car they tell
us that over and over again new green
deals socialist democrats care about one
thing
power power over the democratic power
party power over the white house and
power over we the american people
climate hysteria it's really just the
front as we pointed out at the time they
unveiled this insanity has nothing to do
with the environment it has everything
to do with redistribution of wealth and
socialism the earth is not ending we are
not doomed no one really believes that
lie the religious climate alarmist cult
is really just a means to an ends but
like all cults once you're in to have a
hard time leaving if at all once you're
in you're in so no matter how bad things
get no matter how low biden biden's poll
numbers go he will stay the course and
double down and triple down on stupid
and that's why today biden's climate
czar john curry
stepped off his private jet and
announced that the administration's war
on fossil fuels will continue no matter
how high gas prices go just got off his
own little private jet nice big fat
carbon footprint that he left behind
take a look
unabated fossil fuel is allowed to grow
in these next years in a significant way
as it appears
poised to do
that is a deep
unbelievably costly challenge for the
world it's been reported that you told
the white house national climate advisor
gina mccarthy
that the new u.s commitment on fossil
fuels needed to be at least 50
reductions by 2030 for the u.s to be a
credible negotiator
is that a goal that's still realistic
well gina mccarthy didn't need me to
suggest a level and so gina and her team
and the rest of us who were involved in
the process
all agreed that a 50 to 52 percent
reduction
was was something we could achieve it's
realistic
let me interpret this for you he does
not care about the high price of
everything a 40-year record high
inflation record high gas prices record
high prices for everything you buy in
every store he cares more about his
climate religious cult another top biden
advisor also also reassuring democrats
that biden remains absolutely committed
to banning drilling on public lands this
is a dumb idea take a look
president biden remains absolutely
committed to not moving forward with
with additional drilling on public lands
the challenge that we faced was that we
had a court that ordered that a new
lease to be done
the department of energy had no choice
but to put it out but they also find
found ways to reduce the size of that
and its impact and we'll keep doing what
we need to do to appeal those decisions
and to make our case in a court
ultimately the administration's war on
oil and gas this is a massive scam as
biden restricts domestic production of
fossil fuels think about this now we're
buying more fossil fuels from places
like iran and iraq and he's sending
emissaries to venezuela and he's begging
saudi arabia opec nations until recently
russia the administration has literally
been begging opec to produce more oil of
course that oil is extracted abroad
without epa regulations and then it's
shipped on a gas-powered boat across the
ocean that's how it gets here in other
words biden's restrictions are actually
making the environment worse and energy
even more expensive all while putting
your and our national security at risk
but none of that matters to joe biden
and his fellow new green deal democratic
socialists the only way to stop them is
to vote them out of office that's the
only solution i see they're not going to
change their minds they're locked into
this insanity we are now stuck until at
least november and then probably till
november of 2024 these policies will
remain in place they have absolutely no
desire to change anything as you just
heard now today speaker pelosi she did
unveil the democratic party's big new
strategy for the midterms i know this
might be shocking to many of you but
they're going to call republicans racist
and sexist and misogynist and homophobic
and xenophobic islamophobic transphobic
they're going to say we want dirty air
and water they want that we want grandma
and grandparty dog food and cat food and
then we'll have a republican mean person
like donald trump look like throw granny
over the cliff in a wheelchair take a
look
now i don't paint all of those very
wealthy people as racist anti-semites
and whatever
trumpian
but that's how they vote
all right without fail every two years
four years i used to say it was two
years four years it's now pretty much
every day republicans racist sexist the
whole speech they say it every single
day this year the smears will be worse
than ever because democrats have nothing
positive to run on how do you run on a
40-year high of inflation blaming putin
that's not going to work record setting
gas prices because of the policies you
implemented interest rates on the rise i
mean they're they're going up
precipitously a looming recession war in
europe americans trapped in afghanistan
by the way
249 days and joe biden turned the page
and never mentions them again the media
mob never mentions the americans we
abandoned and of course thousands of
people with green cards eligible to live
here our afghan allies never get
mentioned the crisis on our southern
border well the month of march last
month was the worst ever and it's about
to get even worse hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else